[Music]
in really trip bonding new ally Road
chips submitted by yesterday's leftovers
tuition I don't keep them turn inside i
right yeah I love leftover so great
after an eight-hour ride this uber
driver and NFL player became friends
eight hours damn can you hire someone on
uber for eight hours yeah so can I go on
and be like you know what today I feel
like going to San Francisco and I just
get it over to San Francisco they accept
you're right how do they know the
destination no they know you're the
destination once they pick you up
that's whack they drive all in I years
old oh I'm going to San Francisco birth
father that's happened to me a couple
times too where I ordered uber to go to
the airport and they're like oh you're
going all the way over there and I go I
can't go that way
and they reject you there yeah well they
could ask you to cancel but you don't
have to and if you do they get some
mockers I know you got a B bro
well I feel kind of bad for them because
I don't what this guy he has to do
another eight-hour trip getting back I
thought they know where you're going
that's all about snow even in this
article they state that uber drivers
don't know and he'll be last to [ __ ]
yeah dude I got must've been so pissed
picking them up like getting in the car
ly okay if I was on I'm really bored
dick face I would just get right to New
York and when they show up and then they
say like I don't want to take you down
like fine I'll leave a bad review but
they can also review youtube / reviews
the writers well yeah so like if you if
you're somebody out there who never ever
gets picked up and they cancelled on you
you should no wife is you have a
terminating I on the other hand just
found out I have a four point eight so
know who the [ __ ] gave me a four I
should have a five I fan-fucking-tastic
you [ __ ] does left also rate both ways
- I think it's your super okay only is
this I'm a great goober writer do you
talk to her no I always talk to them
what are they here getting talked to you
guys are like oh god I'm just doing my
bangs I think sometimes they they give
you like a four start if you don't pick
them which is in mandatory how do you
tip them and when you ask you pay the
car I put a tipping feature into oberon
ow soon they have it now I think because
I wouldn't mind giving a tip to my uber
guy if they're really great but if
you're just sitting there not talking
about it I'll still give you a five star
but you
money but you have to eight hours I feel
like they deserve like give me $100 tip
oh for sure
well wait did you find out how much he
got so and then he got that much this
driver famous had B he's an Iranian
refugee I've been in the country for few
years now and he picked up Sharif right
and I fell player don't you at the
Chicago O'Hare International Airport and
when you pick them up he told him that
he had just missed his connection flight
to get to Buffalo and if he could take
him there he thought like okay Buffalo
Illinois cool it's only three hours I'm
talking New York and he's like uh no
Buffalo New York so that's a whole
eight-hour ride adi he was like no
problem let's do it let's go
and so Sheree was saying that he'd not
once did he ever complain about the fact
that he has to take them so far away but
the only thing he would complain about
is slow drivers who'd be like all my
gosh is going 60 miles an hour yeah she
was so determined to get me there on
time because he was heading toward to
his first day of voluntary practice mmm
I thought burgers and cab drivers don't
mind when people are going slow because
isn't it better for them not for uber
because there are paid based off
distance not time
what faster it takes to get into better
know there's a driver know who this guy
was like he's like I'm a fan Kelly I'll
take you down it was a little before
poplars tubular please yeah I keep
didn't know who he was he's just a big
black guy but I'll take you there I mean
II ended up getting to know him
obviously that whole entire trip they
were talking about each other's lives
and they really really bonded till this
day they still keep in contact
oh really cool to be 26 years old do you
like dogs I love dogs
what do you have I have a cocker spaniel
I got a chihuahua so what brings you
this come country I motofuji
she was really touched by his story and
like the reasons why he even came over
which he said that they're too painful
in a shared public publicly but sure
even saying like Abbott his story was
really moving my friends Iranian but he
calls himself Persian most Iranians do
that
yeah the shrink and here's I see his
over bill
yeah 632 dollars in eight is that normal
I don't know I mean there's a lot of
money for a ride
but he made sick conscious process just
do it eight-hour drive and it makes six
hundred bucks a day I don't
yeah well Charisse actually ended up
tipping him $300 so this was nine
hundred thirty two dollars and eight
cents so does that mean yes it drives
back and it's another eight hours the
poor guy you could work on the way back
though yeah he could drive but it takes
like 12 more houses I ended up taking
him to his practice right on time with a
few minutes of spare at 7:00 a.m. so he
was just really truth is really grateful
that he did all that and he was so sweet
throughout the whole time they were
bonding the whole time that's pretty
cool Jim too because I feel like some
celebrities would like hop in a new
bridges bag Nana and don't talk to me oh
my god if i eight hour drive and i guy
want to talk about kill myself so please
possibly but like so long say something
really I'm complete opposite no I mean I
need to have a conversation man
especially after I shot the Tim and we
got drunk and I was talking them up I
got crazy drunk it [ __ ] going back I
don't know what else ain't a problem
gave him my [ __ ] baby on number bro
maybe some cash to get my credit card
bro just because the numbers hit it in
come on do you think a picture you know
I'll take a picture my phone off Simba
two years attention there's a pen comer
don't you that the key call in the back
so the trick with him is just stay in
the car with them long enough here we
get a bank account alcohol yeah get him
drunk kilometer that see what I was
paying for [ __ ] when he's drunk oh I
hate being wrong yeah well next time we
hang out the height is pretty shoddy
just enough just a little bit you know
what you bananas a tough time let me
limit if we erect have you guys tried
the other options on him were like
there's over the angry X in the big yard
line I got this suburban to pick me up
it was dope why did you need a sapphire
pen well I was taking Mary a lot for her
birthday although I got the the bomb
uber to come get us and it was pretty
dope they have like water everything the
suburban it's just so like a limo
basically
like that the call over black or so yeah
there's like black Excel is just failing
the app yeah
oh so the cool thing I mean you know
what you [ __ ] kids are so lucky dude
you don't even have to order a limo
ahead of time let's get a [ __ ] Boober
Excel and that's it takes you there
drops you off holy right mind blowing
not nothing sink like back in the day
we'd have to like to go to prom anyways
that we'd have to like do all I know and
like money from everyone oh my gosh do
they still have stress limo
yeah yeah stretch Escalade I'm sure
there's like a goober limo yeah I
remember back in the day you would feel
a limo you're like oh no it's like Oh
Lane they're going to come together or
something
I didn't realize how [ __ ] comfortable
Suburbans are yeah really good not maybe
not to drive but to be driven in is
amazing because I know some of those
like big fancy cars they don't really
have like safety both do the house yeah
well they still have this about you have
the suburban does I'm like super weird
about that kind of stuff whenever I'm in
a car even if it's like got a school bus
and they don't have a safety but I just
feel weird no no you're so safe no I
just feel weird because like I'm so used
to it I'm sorry she's getting in and
like going this late if you're in a car
and like a bus you don't know what can
happen if nothing chips your out if I if
I drove Gruber I would install TVs in
the back like what the hell thing is so
they could just watch and like enjoy and
have like a private time yeah I mean you
can't even do a particular thing not
want them jacking off back there I'd be
tied yes it's like one click is like
pornhub here and the other ones didn't
know my kid shows what pornhub kiddies
open yeah you can watch Moana first and
then jack off to there you don't know
where you're going to pick up oh I just
played both at the same time okay part
of the mm you know I was gonna get Cara
freakin freak yeah so yeah poor
knowledge of Kitchell yep yeah yeah
there was this energy drink company that
heard about this entire road trip and
wanted to reimburse Yuri's for his trip
sent him a check but then as Fisheries
was like not my my homie Hadean means it
more than me so he ended up sending it
to him whoa
Oh nine hundred thirty two dollars and
eight cents oh wow that's so cool that
is so day that's actually really cool
because um Hugh's trying to make it to
7:00 a.m. practice right for me if I was
an athlete I do like all right driver
I'm sorry but I don't have to shut the
[ __ ] up so I'm trying to sleep as much
as I can before I get to practice yeah
he's pretty much taking a red-eye in the
uber yeah but forehand means I [ __ ] I
miss connect with this dude in any pull
all nighters going to practice yeah well
what a cool guy yeah I need that
[ __ ] talk to me I basically been
this I have it because I would maybe if
I also just say hey man I'm a knockout
for a couple hours but when I wake up
better get your conversation I'll mix
I'm trying to get to know you [ __ ] are
you kind of scared if I don't know the
person like we're going to pull all
nighters like I don't know your driving
skills well I like it like for example
the other day I I got it uber to drop me
off at the saucer place and him so much
I was like you guys posture like oh come
again miss officer 13 falls away oh yeah
he was nice to me though so it's like
watching I just came from sausage so
dope come so cool okay but this guy is
really really freaking cool because I
would sleep to like I remember sometimes
I would wake up for my like four set and
we'd wake up like 5:00 in the morning
and we've already had a full night's
sleep but I get in the car and I'd be
like you know just because you're tired
David Byrne unless last events block
because I [ __ ] love Boston we had a
cast driver and even like that sometimes
I just be like too tired Tom man man
zoomy zoomy New Zealand which is like
shareable it's local and everything is
good for the economy but you'd be out at
like 11:00 at night and there's nobody
writing those things and that's the only
app you guy you're screwed you like yeah
well I'm walking home hey guys would you
think of that video I know you loved it
so make sure to hit that like button to
watch more videos check it out appear
[Music]